we're considering graphing functions
that are made up of two other functions
right so you've got some function and
what it is is another function plus or
minus still another function
okay now I'll start off with some
examples of functions that you can
figure out without doing this that you
can use our rational functions methods
from before but we're going to progress
into methods where when you look at this
the the whole function as a whole right
you really can't do much with it so you
sort of have to resort to looking at
these two especially we call them
component functions right and thinking
about what these to do and then putting
them together okay so let's do our first
example let's consider y equals x plus
so what would this thing look like now
like I said before I don't have to
consider this as two separate functions
if I don't want to write what I could do
first is I could get these on a common
denominator right so this would be x
squared on x + 1 X is my common
denominator so I could treat this as x
squared plus 2 upon X right and then you
could do your normal rational functions
business with it and it's fine okay
however I want to teach you the tricks
that work with these two right and
treating them separately so that when we
get to stuff like say this right which
you can't put together into a nice the
rational function you'll know what to do
okay so the way we treat these two is by
graphing them first so if you've got
another color on you or just use your
pencil and do it lightly first let's
graph these two and see if we can add
them together
sir
okay now I'm pretty sure my um my
scanner looks pretty awful here in a
sense it so doesn't matter for now
because I'm just using these as sort of
guideposts okay all right now I'm trying
to add these two graphs together right
and try to add me together so what I
want to think of that is to visualize
what each one is doing and then see what
happens on Adam okay so example will
start from the left hand mursalin will
go will progress all the way to the
right okay what's happening over here
how would you describe each graph well
you've got a negative value right and
it's sort of an ever increasingly
negative value and another negative
value but this one's really small right
big negative value little negative
values so when you add them together
what would happen we'll take from the
more important factor and then add the
the smaller less important factor okay
from this one do you think my result
when I add them together would be above
or below this line down here it'll be
below right because that's the effect
that this negative would have okay so in
fact you could literally get your ruler
can literally get your ruler out if
you've drawn this well enough which I
haven't and say well okay at a point
let's say here okay
suppose you measured that distance there
between that that little gap and Sora
was like I don't know a centimeter okay
so then you would say well that means
this centimeter will translate to a
centimeter down here where I should be
let's make our lines straight first
lower does that make sense
you see so negative plus negative equals
more negative okay now what happens is I
go towards the right okay I've got one
line that's increasing getting close to
the positive and the other one which is
decreasing it was negative start with
and now it's getting more and more
negative okay so as I move to the right
the question I ask you is which one is
more
which one takes over as it were okay so
you saw when I looked at this point here
this one was a more significant value
than this one up here this one's almost
negligible right but over here the game
changes right what happens this curve
here the two over X so it becomes a more
significant value and more significant
part of the function okay I'm going to
use that language a lot more significant
less significant because I kind of try
to get the general shape of things okay
so again instead of going closer to this
line I'm going to go closer the more
significant one am I going to be above
or below it again I'm going to be below
right because to the left of this axis
everything is negative okay so you could
take your rule that again measure down
and take a point like say here I should
be below okay now what happens in
between here hmm well I can tell you
what it's not going to be okay it's not
going to be a straight line how do I
know it's not going to be a straight
line because it sort of looks like you
know from here to here I could just how
do I know how do you know it can't
because there's a curve here all right
good okay so I'm trying to get this
interaction between two different
functions right and true if I had one
curve that was going up like this right
and another curve that was going down
like this because they're both curved
there and they're both going equally
they would cancel each other out right
but it's not the scenario we have here
one skirt so in other words it's
decreasing rapidly right and it's
increasing more rapidly as I go this
one's increasing but it's not speeding
up just going chugging along at the same
rate okay so therefore I'm going to get
a curve in here as well something like
this
okay
now I put arrows on the end here because
I know I'm going to get some asymptotic
behavior but the question for you is how
I know how do I know there are
asymptotes I'm describing to number one
one over this way and number two one
down here okay
so much